we got a winner in the building I'm so
excited I can't believe this I can come
on I can't I mean we literally wrote the
song five years ago as like we didn't
even think anything of it and we didn't
think anything we didn't break it dude
you wrote an Anthem yeah I mean I it's
amazing yeah well you got a new blue
outfit on right here the whole thing is
the blue Vibe we're doing we're doing
blue Vibes I love it your performance
was very blue how did it feel on stage
it was very nerve-wracking but it felt
Energy felt incredible yeah yeah I love
watching you perform and I couldn't help
but think about how another very
powerful woman was in the audience
watching Taylor Swift oh my God
dancing she was vibing along I know I
mean I know you're a huge fan of her yes
when are we gonna get the BB Taylor
collab whether it's behind the scenes
writing or together on a track which is
what I'm hoping I mean hopefully soon I
think she's incredible and I think she's
not only an incredible artist but an
incredible writer and I really respect
that as a songwriter I know two
songwriters we need the two of you
together Taylor call me
I just have to tell you I love following
you on Instagram you seem like you're
just in such a beautiful season of Life
your career is ascending you seem so
happy with your relationship my body
store
come on baby
my goal is to meet you that wasn't
incredible before thank you so much I
really appreciate it thank you you're
amazing I really appreciate it thank you
so much thank you let's have a dream
crafter yes please wait are you gonna
get the party or no are you gonna go I
didn't know it was an offer I'm not I'm
not up there that you baby I didn't I
didn't know there was an off the party
you have good like you're like oh you
know yeah
I'll catch you in a bit yeah
look at you you're the mayor of this
place
me himself oh my God I love it he's
awesome I love him yeah his music is
fire your career just continues to
explode you're in seemingly such a happy
relationship how do you think about like
taking the next step when there is so
much going on with your career oh my
gosh I think right now I I I'm focusing
on my career for a little bit more yeah
I mean I have my boyfriend and like we
have balance which is amazing to be able
to go home and to like you know just
like because it gets lonely sometimes so
to have him is like amazing but right
now I think I'm just really focused on
finishing a new album and just you know
it takes a lot look I mean traveling for
three weeks right now I know my last
question 2023 is shaping up to be your
biggest Year I hope so what are you most
excited to give your fans my new music
I'm really really excited about it's
really different and it's unexpected but
it's still danceable so I'm really
excited about it in three words
oh I can't give away too much but um
I'll say dance 70s
something like that new BB New Era of BB
congratulations
[Music]